(tirs)
- Une scène tournée
par un vidéaste amateur
au coeur de Port-au-Prince.
Des policiers tentent
de déjouer des membres
de gangs.
D'autres quartiers sont
simplement abandonnés
par les forces de l'ordre.
De jeunes hommes lourdement
armés y opèrent en
toute impunité.
Et les dernières victimes sont
les enfants de la commune
de Cité-Soleil à Port-au-Prince
qui ont fui les affrontements.
Quelque 300 d'entre-eux ont
trouvé refuge dans une école.
Marilove a vu une élève perdre
la vie dans un échange
de coup de feu.
- La situation est complexe,
essentiellement deux bandes
tent; les G-Pèp et
les G-9, menés par l'ancien
policier tristement célèbre
sur les réseaux sociaux
Jimmy Chérizier.
ÉTIENNE COTÉ-PALUCK,
journaliste indépendant
- Ils attaquent certains zones
qu'ils aimeraient controler.
Le groupe qui les affrontent
est un groupe qui n'est pas
nécessairement un groupe
uniformes. C'est un groupe
qui s'appelle G-Pèp,
surnommé en tout cas comme ça,
et eux défendent leur quartier
en disant : "Non, nous on veut
la sécurité dans notre quartier.
On veut contrôler
notre quartier."
- Les flambées de violence ne
sont pas nouvelles à Port-au-
Prince, mais la montée rapide
de ces gangs est préoccupante
pour les Nations unies.
En seulement 6 mois,
l'ONU recense 934 meurtres,
684 blessés et 680 enlèveme
À Montréal, le sujet fait partie
des conversations des membres
de la diaspora.
KENNY MARCHAND, propriétaire,
MK Électro menager
- Ça me touche. De jour en jour,
quand j'entends qu'est-ce
qui se passe en Haïti.
- Et Nous sommes fs sommes fs st
tombés sur ceux qui ont été pris
pour cible comme cette mère.
- Pendant que je sortais
de l'école avec mon fils,
on a essayé de nous kidnapper.
J'ai parlé avec mon mari. Je lui
ai dit que... : "Non, Je ne peux
pas rester là-bas. Je ne sais
pas ce qui va se passer après."
- Cet anla question
haïtienne tient sur les réseaux
sociaux des émissions dédiées
à l'histoire d'Haïti et
sa politique. Il soulève
une série de questions.
JEAN FILS-AIMÉ, analyste, poli.,
anim., "Lumière sur le monde"
- D'où viennent ces armes-là?
Par où elles transitent?
Qui a l'argent pour les acheter?
Qui a l'autorité pour les faire
rentrer et, la cinquième
question, je ne sais plus
à quelle question je suis
maintenant, c'est
finalité? Je crois que c'est
la question la plus importante!
- Il fait partie de ceux
qui prônent une solution
interne à la crise.
- La soi-disant communauté
internationale doit laisserauxïr
une solution intra-haitienne.
- Les pays amis, cnada
et les États-Unis, prônent
une solution haitienne celle
qui passerait par des élections
organisées par le gouvernement
en placernementrnementrnementrnt
qui a montré peu résultats
jusqu'à présent dans sa lutte
contre la violence.
Ici Mélissa François, Montréal